hello and welcome to this video playing
SMS m3m yes I've had a couple of games
against him with this opening with mixed
results I remember something some weird
things that somehow I am we had this we
had this what was that s 5 I don't
remember I don't remember okay check
yeah always forget how this is played
him let's be let's just play quickly and
let's see what happens
yeah white I mean why does the temporary
development advantage if it doesn't
translate into something black will just
be very very very very much better King
is 795 94 and so on
it's kind of a typical trade of in bliss
yeah yeah this is an opening that can
never be really good I mean with the
bishop pair given up and so on it's
something that in classical time control
chest probably won't fail all that well
but in blitz it's it's quite tricky i
mean 96 so maybe he has find some tricks
and checkmates me or something like that
yeah let opens that opens my king
absolutely i knew there might be some
tricks as i said also we have to check
here and 94 or not see for immediately
and it will be a complete mess but it's
really funny let's try it yeah I don't
don't see why it doesn't work so let's
try it when he moves the bishop there's
an immediate knight c6 maybe he takes
like Bishop before so that that would be
for that would be cool this more I
didn't expect this at all as usual so I
can check and we should did you okay
which which looks like a twin stuff but
if he moves this bishop there is 96 so
it's completely completely a chaotic
seacoast Bishop takes e4 can I just play
Bishop d7 I mean it's got to look
hanging and the night hanging you know
it just gives up stuff so i can check
here no he's actually doing is actually
attacking or threatening it like this
okay wakey wakey wakey so this one we
should heal check and then stirred win
stuff right takes ages take ages to see
it but it wins material okay takes here
that's 90s b5 check check so I have one
piece
okay just got one point for it like
recently who I always tough here and I
just don't believe in this this whole
line at all I mean it cannot be right to
deflect the pair of bishops and and this
pawn advantage in the center I mean it
might be equal objectively speaking it
but it's just okay completely against
what i think is right yes somehow and
I've analyzed it ones i think if why
play that correctly it is it is it is
equal because of his work because of
white some development edge this week
when I cannot quite believe it I've got
this really nice diagonal as a compound
agrees just wants to take on d4 and this
this is a data to Tamil he goes these
three am Bishop b5 is the critical move
I am I saw that I can chicken check on
the torch I wasn't really sure so check
can't check yeah and now I didn't really
know what was going on we should be
seven as the engine smooth equal or
light slide advantage Sherman I don't
know it was completely chaotic okay and
that does it doesn't seem to work him
you know this I was thinking just Bishop
d7 could be an idea but then he's got
night f5 okay
so then I have to take the stand go for
this variation I mean I so material up
here but it's it's a bit wacky with the
night on a three Wow chekea Genesis ok
this is using a pj what yeah it's always
always tricky if you have this
development problems ok guys thanks for
watching